sébastien martinez joël taurins sont
éleveurs à sauvigny les bois 40 vaches
laitières 60 allaitantes confronté au
niveau des cours de la viande de
l'exploitation familiale et souvent
démunis face à la mainmise des
distributeurs ne disent que les grandes
enseignes
ils ont des charges tout ça mais nous
aussi on a nos charges nos charges qui
augmentent d'année en année
est ce qu'on vendait ces mêmes prix que
du temps de nos parents même grands
parents on se bat tous les jours se
pressaient d'y arriver quoi ce qu'on
veut c'est vivre on ne monte pas d'être
riche mais cette vivre décemment pour le
laisser il veut passe par une laiterie
coopérative et transforme d'une partie
de leur production en fromage écoulée
directement ou moyennes et grandes
surfaces
localement les accords se font sans
accroc moi ça se passe relativement bien
j'ai pas de souci avec eux directement
jeune âge a fait choux ont pris je le
redis mon prix
une prennent à mon prêt mais
actuellement le couple ne peut se verser
qu'un salaire pour 2 alors remettre
l'éleveur au coeur du système l'idée est
encourageante mais la méfiance reste de
mise
comme vous voyez qu'en grande surface
c'est faut compter dans les deux rôles
kg et que nous un veau entier sur pied
on nous paye 20 euros pass avec c'était
une promesse de monsieur m'a conquis bon
là ça qu'on peut pas dire il prend les
choses en main a espéré oui à espérer
que ça prenne une tournure bombe à tous
qu'alimentation causé ces cours cours
mondiaux alors cela ferait la demande
puis bon il ya quand même beaucoup de
spéculations aussi sur moi de très dur
pour concrétiser les espoirs il faudra
réussir à peser dans les discussions
s'entendre et défendre son travail pour
conserver une agriculture qui fait vivre
ces éleveurs